eu countries have begun the biggest mass
vaccination program in their history
members will be pushing for more
transparency on how the eu procures and
decides on covid19 vaccines
the election of joe biden as us
president is a chance for the eu and the
new u.s administration to restore the
transatlantic partnership
parliaments will debate proposals for
closer cooperation with washington
from tackling the pandemic and its
fallout to climate policy
trade and promoting democracy
portugal took the reins of the rotating
presidency of the council of the eu
on the 1st of january lisbon will
present the european parliament with its
priorities for the upcoming six months
since the beginning of the pandemic
nearly one in three europeans has worked
from home
meps will call for new rules to protect
people's free time from work related
calls
emails and messages parliament is
committed to reaching gender equality in
europe
meps will set their position on the eu
strategy for gender equality
and debate how to include women in the
digital economy and how covid19
has affected their rights
you